you absolutely need to focus on your
accuracy of grass for these next little
bits we have talked before bless you
about the difference but I just want to
remind you about the difference between
graphing something just as a kind of
like a tool to get to something else
like I've given a problem they don't ask
me to graph but a graph is very useful
as opposed to when graphing is the thing
that you are producing okay so because
at the moment we're focusing on the
graph as the object that you're actually
you know putting forward I think this is
worth three marks you've really got a
bank on it and make it a really
important shape okay so we're going to
begin the most basic cubic equation that
we can start with is y equals x cubed
okay and as we have a look at this we're
going to focus on some of the things
that make it very similar to shapes that
we've looked at before most namely the
parabola the quadratic okay they are
after all are the same family by the way
that's probably worth mentioning this
whole family quadratics cubics does
anyone know what it would be called if
we change this to a four we've actually
said this name off here but haven't
dealt with it specifically when it's a
power of four we call this a quartic
quartic as in like quarter like four
right anyone won't make any guesses if
it was five Pentek is a good guess and
to be honest the actual name is quintic
right I don't I don't know if one's like
Latin or one's Greek Pentagon because
you don't have Quinta guns anyway these
continue going up and up and up
we'll get to will get to that second who
later on but all of these money all of
these are in the family of objects
called polynomials right so these are
all all of these guys okay and as a
consequence you have a lot of similar
qualities between these here's the first
thing I'm going to start with you know
when you graph a function of any kind
then one of most important features
you're going to put on here are the
intercepts right the intercepts so I
want you to have a think with me how
much you get at in Sep intercept any
kind of intercept out of this how do you
usually find something like say a
y-intercept what do you do you let X
equal zero and then you get y equals
something else right so if I put x
equals zero into this when x equals zero
right by the way really really minor
thing I'm going to say I'm going to
suggest I'm gonna encourage you to write
this working then I'm about to put down
here alongside your graph here because
it's gonna help inform your thoughts and
it might seem like a little thing but I
encourage you to write the word when
you're like why do I have to put words
here when when okay I'll explain why I'm
not saying let in a minute okay I'm not
going to just say x equals zero and then
do a theme okay because the whole point
behind have an equation like this is
that X can be well let me ask you this
question what does it look like the
domain we've been thinking about domain
and range before what does it look like
the domain of this function will be this
I can put pretty much any x value I like
it here it doesn't break any rules
you're never going to take the square
root of a negative number there are no
square roots you're never going to
divide by zero there's no division in
here okay so I could put any X in here
you like and the whole point is X can be
anything but sometimes it takes on
particular values and they're going to
be on our graph right so when x equals
zero
what will y equal
I'm gonna do the substitution I'm not
even gonna think about it yet I'm just
gonna do the substitution and then you
can tell me what it means I'm gonna
write zero instead of X everywhere I see
X in this thing which is only once and
then I'm going to write the rest of it
right zero cubed of course is that's
zero zero times zero zero zero so when
you see this right
what that means is and this part I'm
gonna ask you to write down but in the
future you're gonna start - you're gonna
stop writing this because I've become
like a parent to you right what I can
say is on the basis of this write that
I've got an x and a y together this is a
pair of coordinates right so what this
is saying is zero zero right there's the
X there's y is a point on my graph right
once when I do this that's the
conclusion I draw 0 0 is a point on y
equals x cute on my graph okay so I'm
gonna go ahead and I'm going to place
that onto my set of axes okay well by
the way I probably should have labeled
those you get the idea okay now we could
keep on doing this for a while but it
looks like we've got an x intercept and
y intercepts all in one that's a nice
bonus okay as I think about what's going
to happen as I put in other values if I
were to put in I'm not gonna write these
anymore if I were to put in 1 for X what
would I get
I would get y equals 1 so 1 comma 1 is
another point on my graph I'm gonna
place that here 1 1 okay when I put 2
into here what's why I got to be equal
to it's gonna be 8 this thing is
skyrocketing and it's correctly fast
right so if I go across the two I'm
already up here at 8 does that make
sense to combat eight is a point on my
graph so you can see this thing is sort
of matching up all the way right it's
gonna climb fast in fact I already no
longer have space on my graph anyway to
put the next thing if X were equal to 3
what would Y be equal to 27 3 cubed is
27 so it's way off my set of axes so
okay it's gonna be up the top right so
that's what's happening on the left hand
side it's getting steeper and steeper
and steeper as we go so I could actually
connect up the dots sort of the
over here I could say ah this is gonna
sort of come down like this it starts
off nice and slow and then it just kind
of races off really really fast up in
the positive direction okay it's not a
great graph but I'm gonna run with it
still I think it's close enough for our
purposes
okay so I've got the positive side of
this but we established before the
domain also exists over on the left
right when I put negative values into
here though unlike when we thought about
the quadratics right the quadratic the
parabola is going to go off in this
direction because when you square a
number what happens to the sign it's
always gonna be positive right so you
stay up above right
but this doesn't happen for the cubic
does it right if it goes down because if
you were to put this what is worth
writing right if I put in x equals
negative 1 right so I can take on this
value 2y is going to be equal to just be
careful how you write this yeah
especially when you put this into a
calculator you can get quite confused
because your calculator will tell you
exactly what it is you asked for unless
you asked it wrong okay yeah so this is
negative 1 cubed as opposed to I'm gonna
don't write this down as opposed to
negative 1 cubed right these are two
different things it just so happens
coincidentally at the moment they're the
same that's just negative 1 but your
calculator thinks about these
differently right it's good to go
negative 1 times negative 1 times
negative 1 you're brave the thing about
differently as well right exactly right
if I did negative 1 squared those are
quite different aren't they yeah if you
have your calculator there you have you
came here if it's not get it out if you
pop this into your calculator right
what's he going to do what does it
actually tell you yeah no bracket it
says oh I know what it has an order of
operations built-in yeah it squares the
one right and then it's like oh you want
a negative as well no problem I'll give
you decorative one right but of course
the negative one if we did this twice
it'd be negative one times negative one
they would cancel okay so what does this
tell us right I can say therefore
negative one negative one that's on my
graph right I'm gonna put the
there I'm gonna make sure this is
consistent and you can see there is
going to be a symmetry to this graph
right
what kind of symmetry is it we have a
name for this don't we it's the day it
has rotational symmetry I could spin
this this graph I could spin it around
so it goes sort of down like this right
what's the name of this
it's odd symmetry isn't it and we
actually to remind you because I know
with mrs. Lee's you looked at this
already part of the way you can know why
odd symmetry is called odd symmetry is
have a look at the power right it's an
odd number and in fact any polynomial
which has this kind of structure is
going to have this kind of symmetry okay
all right now this is more or less y
equals x cubed say it again minus 2
minus 8 because it's going down isn't it
ok you could put more points on to get
more detail if you want it now I'm
pretty happy with this right this is the
graph of y equals x cubed just for the
sake of it I'm going to re-emphasize
I've got this point here right and I'm
going to draw on here something that
indicates exactly where it is because if
you went to desmos for instance and you
put in y equals x cubed you get a shape
like this right but if you put in
something like y equals to X cubed
you'd get almost exactly the same shape
what will be the difference by the way
it would be slightly different
interesting so there's gonna be some
squishing and scaling but which way I
said what do you think you
right
that's really interesting okay now this
is not our main point okay it's not our
main point but I do want you to want to
think through this with you because you
really want to you're gonna be getting
some of these later on okay if I went
through this same process right let's
have a think about this one right when x
equals zero for that guy over there what
would happen when I went through the
subsidiary x equals zero
yeah it's gonna be two times zero still
0 so y equals two X cubed would still go
through that point there zero zero but
what I think about this guy or I didn't
write it down actually well this one I
do when I put in negative one okay this
is still gonna be the same but there's
gonna be a two at the front right so
what would happened on this line just
for this particular one that we multiply
by 2 gives me negative 2 right so
instead of being here at negative 1
negative 1 I'm going to be at negative 1
and then I'm gonna be twice as far down
I'm gonna be down here at negative 2 do
you agree right and instead of being at
two color hey I'm going to be twice as
high up I'll be at 16 right so you're
gonna get the same kind of shape but
everything is pulled apart like this
it's actually gonna stretch vertically
or if you'd prefer to think about it
that way it's squeezed horizontally they
actually turned out to be the same thing
okay now my point is my point is because
they basically have the same shape but
the difference is only scale you need to
provide some kind of information to
shows you what's kind of scale there is
if I took off all of these numbers you
would not be able to tell whether it was
Mike was X cubed or 2x cubed or 200 X
cubed they all say the same set change
that with me yeah it's um these numbers
he provides some scale on there does
that make sense so an alternative like
saying this say this is exactly the same
it's equivalent to saying this 1 comma 1
if they've got the same amount of
information on there okay and you can do
either I don't think you really
necessarily need to do both because they
say the same thing but you should do one
of them okay but because that indicates
where that is does that make sense